after spending seven hours with the
retail version of Forza Motorsport seven
turn 10 studios as latest appears to
offer something for every kind of
driving enthusiast while its campaign
reports of drivers Cup kicks off with a
mandatory trio of races and various
vehicle types and environments here
subsequently offered many routes to
victory thereafter by the time I clear
the first three of the six chapters I
stuck to my favorite types of cars
namely Japanese and European sports cars
I was also reintroduced to riveting
passing challenges and a novelty of
bowling with cars
all the while open-wheel and muscle car
competitions tempted me to beer outside
my comfort zone
this swath of variety made playing for
seven hours straight feel like a breeze
[Music]
courts of seven maintains the series is
silky smooth frame rate and the granular
scope in which you can customize the
controls to suit your driving style
my current handling preferences favor
tire traction and I was pleased how
closely many of my cars in four to seven
felt like equivalents from drive Club
another favorite racer of mine and it
was comforting to get back on familiar
tracks like Brands Hatch and Laguna Seca
yet it wasn't until I returned to Prague
about three hours into my playthrough
that I felt wholly reunited with port so
the improved lighting effects in
conjunction with the weather and time of
day diversity made the latest version of
this Czech city particularly striking
[Music]
even if you aren't erasing sim purist
four to seven accommodates your desire
to drive thanks to numerous
accessibility settings undoing any on
course mistake with rewind helps ensure
wins
though I prefer the Codemasters approach
and limiting the amount of times you can
do this in a race there's also no
penalty for dangerous driving and
cutting corners clearly turn 10 is
leaving it to you to set your own
definition of airplay I also spent
considerable time trying out the mod
cards consumables that you can apply to
any Cup race for an added challenge
depending on the card you can gain bonus
experience for skillful driving placing
well and turning off select assists some
of these mods added a modicum of
increased stakes and competitive tension
while also offering incentives for
novices to experiment with the activated
assists and possibly take off select
training wheels for good these cards are
unlocked as part of the games loot
crate's
based off the first dozen crates I
earned and opened for two sevens form of
blind box collectible items offered a
balanced mix of cosmetic and practical
items from driver outfits to cars to add
to your collection unless you want to
sell them as I continue my playthrough
into this weekend I'm looking forward to
dividing my attention between completing
the ports of drivers Cup and finally
participating in online races while the
once innovative friends as AI drive at
our competition remains engaging it
doesn't compare to the unpredictability
of real players I'm also hoping that the
car model loading times in the garage
improves at lodge for the Xbox one as
currently there are two second wait
times when I quickly scroll through cars
yet this is a mild annoyance compared to
the sad reminder that turned 10 was not
able to secure production model Toyota's
for four to seven while this
manufacturer isn't linked to the series
to the degree its associated with Gran
Turismo it was disappointing to be
limited to a modest selection of Toyotas
not named Celica or mr2 taking the bad
with the good
turn 10 took full advantage of its
recently renewed licensing deal with
Porsche by making at least two dozen of
the German manufacturers cars available
for purchase in-game before I finish
forts of seven I intend to buy the much
sighs 2018 Porsche 911 gt2 RS and put it
through its paces
[Music]
along with my final verdict affords the
drivers cup an online multi-player I'm
hoping to evaluate the Forsyth on timed
events leagues auction house and
marketplace all of which will lock prior
to the game's release you can check back
next week when I'll have posted both my
review and a video review of Forza
Motorsport 7 thanks for watching